that does that look you come up into my
crotch best angle for vlogging because
today is so insanely crazy that I don't
have time to make a full video so I am
vlogging like this on my ride home
because I just had a meeting two
meetings and then I have to get ready to
go to the captain coda premiere party
tonight are you looking it into my
crotch I can't tell and my car mount
this where is it this being fun friend
that's called the super suction car
mount super sucks so I just thought that
we'd have a chat today it's once-over
Wednesday I'm gonna review my ride home
with you right now
here's how it's going right now super
slow sometimes it's fun when people look
at you while you're talking down into
your crotch for this let's just do a
once-over what's in my car right now
how about that this is like what's in my
purse but what's in my car I just bought
these ice breakers ice cubes these are
not this is not gum this is just candy
tiny Tom's cuz my stomach is just a like
Secret Santa you know like things get
passed around and then you don't know
what's gonna be opened up I got my Els
little bomb Oh get out you're sliding
too far to the craft area a tiny
deodorant because I've put together like
a survival kit for being a functioning
human being on the road oh I got Chelsea
Handler's book cuz I did Chelsea Lately
the other night and they gave it to me
as a gift and I was like little do you
know that I don't know how to read I do
here's a nondescript Ralph's water
Ralph's is a grocery store out here
which always makes me think of vomit - I
have a bag
that used to have something in it bath
and Bodyworks
cashmere glow because everyone wants to
smell like a sweater what else do I have
in the car grace up gets you creepy
little perverts you guys all told me not
to vlog and drive when my hand boat so
both hands are on the wheels and you're
just laying in my laughs this is like
wisps those tiny little fake
toothbrushes that you use on the go and
that really it just feels like you're
scraping a mint into your tooth oh I got
a my music t-shirt yeah yeah baby baby
oh here's another bag starting a
collection I should probably go because
I'm trying to have a conversation with
you guys you guys just want the cooter
so I will see you stopping I'm not
taking that yellow like a sea bass
tomorrow don't forget to preorder camp
Takota at Camp Takota commas are like
two more days like one day and a half I
don't know it's bonkers
do you guys want to reek alone I have
some of them idle though Wet Ones
because sometimes to get oh they beefed
at me cuz I was talking to you guys they
didn't know